[Music]
how insane is it to go back
and say yeah you told a joke 15 years
ago and now
i don't like it and you're dead and i'm
going to ruin you and ruin your life
yeah because the context is different
right because you know
it's a lot of times you're not with
comic you're not even
so much people talk about it being like
a truth-telling art form but it's
it's not about so sometimes it's not so
much about telling the truth
as much as being not forced to tell lies
because it's more like everyone's it's
like if uh you know sometimes you'll see
it in
in you know the body positivity movement
with women or whatever they'll go this
girl's so beautiful and you go all right
whatever like
i mean they're like no but say it though
you have to say it you have to believe
it yeah
and you go okay i don't care if you want
to say that and think that
but when you need me to now say it
that's what's becoming a problem
so it's like if you want to go like your
thing that you like fine
but when you need to go no but you need
to say it's good and i think that's like
a lot of times what it's pushing back
against
because the context is different i
wouldn't i'm not like a need to tell the
truth if i'm with
someone that's you know that person
let's say a two out of ten
girl i don't i don't like hey you're
gross because i'm a truth teller and i
need to say this
that's not how i feel but if ten people
are in my face being like
tell her she's beautiful i then i might
be like well she's not though no
i stopped making me beyond i don't wanna
be honest i don't wanna say anything but
yeah i mean it's i mentioned it earlier
now it's become a kind of cliche is this
idea of
stunning and brave you know that
basically there's this kind of
i don't know politically correct
orthodoxy that makes you
say i guess it started really with with
caitlyn jenner is you say okay bruce
jenner wants to go by caitlyn jenner now
all right doesn't really bother me it
doesn't
you know no big deal i have other things
that i think about
but it's when you're told that you have
to
say this what this woman is stunning and
brave yeah i mean even
i think nor nor macdonald had a bid on
this he's like look you know they want
me to
say that she's brave and beautiful and
uh maybe she's brave but
like how many 60 something year old
women do you know who are like really
really hot not too many you know yeah in
their own way but
but not not too many yeah that's it's
just a culture of lies that's being
being forced in on people and that kind
of makes you react
yeah and people are like over it you
know so when you give them the
permission
to not uh say that because a lot of
times uh you know comedy can be like a
pressure release valve right
because there's so much of uh people
feel like they're being gas lit right
it's kind of
so sometimes it's just nice to go up and
hear someone kind of say those things
the same way that
if you let's say me and you had a mutual
friend who's he's all right you know
not maybe a guy number four in the crew
and so
and everyone's coming up to you and
they're like this guy's the best all of
a sudden you find yourself in your head
like what and then everyone's telling
you that and then so that's making you
feel crazy but then when someone else
comes up like
hey he just had a really bad day so
we're just trying to get bump him up and
you go oh
yeah sure great guy yeah he's awesome i
just don't want to feel crazy
yeah yeah a lot of times you know when
just hearing someone push back against
these things
is enough to sort of you know because
sometimes you're in your workplace
you're like am i crazy
because you feel is ever has everyone
lost their minds it starts to make you
feel crazy because you're being like
gaslit by society sometimes yeah is that
gaslighting i think
you know sometimes the right gets
knocked for being too
too blunt or you know they're they're
they're considered mean or impolite but
it's not that
we'd be happy to be polite it's just
don't
like relieve yourself on my leg and tell
me it's raining just let me know what
you're doing and
that it's not i'm not completely out of
my mind and we can go along and be nice
and all have a nice civil society
yeah i think that everyone works a
little better when they're the
push i mean it's a weird scenario
because obviously the trump's in power
so you have the republicans in power
but the liberals clearly controlled
thought and everything everything else
yeah yeah so you have a it's kind of it
feels like for me like the whole woke
church
it's the reason why people are so
threatened is because they have their
bishop positions in that church
and then and they're saying you know
here's our list of things and
i'm kind of saying hey we have a bar
down the street where we're
we're all kind of partying and it's
really fun and everyone's leaving to go
hang out at that bar and they're like
just so you know you're we're gonna
we're gonna call you the worst things if
you leave
because they if they know if you leave
it's a bishop position and they go yeah
that's the devil there and you go well
it's not really that we're just having
fun over here and they're like well you
can't
[Music]
[Music]